il y aura un avant et un après 12
octobre le 12 octobre dernier j'ai été
honorée et fière au nom du groupe l'est
républicain de défendre devant
l'assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi en faveur de l'inclusion des enfants
handicapés au sein de l'école de la
république
cette proposition noah a recueilli la
volonté de débat de tous les groupes
politiques
tous les groupes politiques à
l'exception d'un seul le groupe de la
république en marche a eu l'audace
l'audace et la honte
incroyable de déposer une motion de
rejet préalable ils ont refusé toute
discussion sur un projet aussi essentiel
que celui du handicap au sein de notre
école j'ai dénoncé avec l'ensemble de
mes collègues
cette posture cette attitude sectaire
qui ne fait pas honneur à l'engagement
politique et à la mission des députés je
le redis en commission tous les groupes
politiques ont déposé des amendements
pour améliorer ce texte pour le faire
vivre le seul groupe qui n'a pas déposé
un seul amendement et celui des députés
perroquet de la république en marche
je le redis notre proposition permettait
de faire avancer les choses n était
certainement pas parfaite mais elle
permettait sur le statut des
accompagnants qui aujourd'hui sont dans
les situations de précarité extrême de
faire évoluer leur situation de leur
permettre une meilleure formation une
meilleure rémunération
nous avons dans notre pays 80 mille
femmes et hommes qui au quotidien
accompagne nos enfants en situation de
handicap ou leur devons une réponse et
des solutions concrètes
notre proposition de loi permettait de
décloisonner les temps d'accompagnement
vous le savez comme moi la réussite d'un
enfant se fait autant durant le temps
scolaire que durant le temps
périscolaire durant les voyages
scolaires étant notre activité notre
proposition de loi permettait de faire
avancer les choses
enfin notre proposition de loi
permettait de réduire le délai d'examen
des dossiers auprès de la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
c'est un sujet essentiel ce délai
devrait être aujourd'hui de quatre mois
en vérité parfois il dépasse les 9 mois
laissant les familles dans des
situations inextricables
au fond nous avions nous les députés une
responsabilité agir pour ces familles
ses enfants ses accompagnants qui le
plus souvent sont en détresse
le gouvernement les députés de la
république est en marche en refuser la
discussion
ils ont dévoilé leur vrai visage
un visage sectaire un visage qui est
celui de député flemmards qui ne veulent
pas travailler qui ne veulent pas faire
avancer le pays
il y aura un avant et un après 12
octobre dernier et au nom du groupe
l'est républicain
au nom de l'ensemble des députés notre
famille politique nous pouvons être
fiers être fier d'avoir porté haut ce
sujet ce sujet que nous continuerons à
défendre parce qu'il est essentiel pour
notre avenir commun